ciara announces she's expecting her
first child with husband Russell Wilson
baby I'm so excited
God is so good the singer took to
Instagram on her 31st birthday Tuesday
to share the exciting news with fans
posting this adorable photo cozied up
with her hubby holding on to her growing
belly Ciara gushed in the caption quote
on this special birthday I received an
abundance of love from friends and
family and I'm excited to finally share
one of the greatest gifts of all that
God could give the couple's new bundle
of joy will be joining Sierra's
two-year-old son future jr. who she
shares with her ex rapper future the
pair married at a castle in England in
July et's Michelle Turner spoke with
Russell shortly after the nuptials where
he dished on the possibility of
expanding their family Oh take one at a
time you know just we're grateful it
will just take up we're just grateful
opportunity and ultimately you know it's
just about you know spend quality time
with each other
you